Pueden medir la conductabilidad de la piel y las respuestas de sobresalto,
pero no hay necesidad.
Está claro que el chico de azul ha asimilado la mano falsa.
Esto significa que incluso las experiencias de qué es nuestro cuerpo
es una especie de adivinar mejor.
Una especie de alucinación controlada por el cerebro.
Hay una cosa más.
No solo experimentamos nuestros cuerpos como objetos del mundo desde el exterior,
también los experimentamos desde dentro.
Todos experimentamos la sensación de ser un cuerpo desde el interior.
Y las señales sensoriales procedentes del interior del cuerpo
informan continuamente al cerebro sobre el estado de los órganos internos,
qué tal el corazón, la presión sanguínea,
muchas cosas.
Este tipo de percepción, que llamamos interocepción,
se pasa por alto.
Pero es muy importante
porque la percepción y la regulación del estado interno del cuerpo...
Bueno, eso es lo que nos mantiene vivos...
Aquí hay otra versión de la ilusión de la mano de goma.
Esto es de nuestro laboratorio en Sussex.
Y aquí, la gente ve una versión de realidad virtual de su mano,
que parpadea en rojo,
ya sea al ritmo o fuera del ritmo de sus latidos del corazón.
Y cuando parpadea al ritmo de sus latidos del corazón,
las personas tienen una sensación más fuerte que es parte de su cuerpo.
Así que la experiencia de tener un cuerpo está profundamente arraigada
al percibir nuestros cuerpos desde dentro.
Una última cosa sobre la que quiero llamar su atención,
es que las experiencias del cuerpo desde el interior son muy diferentes
de las experiencias del mundo que nos rodea.
Cuando miro a mi alrededor, el mundo parece lleno de objetos...
Mesas, sillas, manos de goma,
gente, Uds.,
incluso mi propio cuerpo en el mundo,
puedo percibirlo como un objeto desde el exterior.
Pero mis experiencias del cuerpo desde dentro,
no es así en absoluto.
No percibo mis riñones aquí,
mi hígado aquí,
mi bazo...
No sé dónde está mi bazo,
pero está en alguna parte.
No percibo mis entrañas como objetos.
De hecho, no las experimento mucho a menos que funcionen mal.
Y esto es importante, creo.
La percepción del estado interno del cuerpo
no está relacionada con averiguar qué hay ahí,
se trata de control y regulación...
de mantener las variables fisiológicas dentro de los límites estrictos
compatibles con la supervivencia.
Cuando el cerebro usa predicciones para averiguar qué hay,
percibimos los objetos como las causas de las sensaciones.
Cuando el cerebro usa predicciones para controlar y regular las cosas,
experimentamos lo bien o lo mal que funciona este control.
Así que nuestras experiencias más elementales de ser un yo,
de ser un organismo encarnado,
están profundamente arraigadas en los mecanismos biológicos
que nos mantienen vivos.
Y cuando seguimos esta idea hasta el final,
podemos ver que todas nuestras experiencias conscientes,
dado que todas dependen de los mismos mecanismos de percepción predictiva,
todo proviene de este impulso básico para mantenerse vivo.
Experimentamos el mundo y a nosotros mismos
con, a través y debido a nuestros cuerpos vivos.
Vincularé las cosas paso a paso.
Lo que vemos conscientemente depende
de la mejor conjetura del cerebro sobre lo que está en el exterior.
Nuestro mundo experimentado viene de adentro hacia afuera,
No solo de fuera hacia adentro.
La ilusión de la mano muestra que esto aplica a nuestras experiencias
de lo que es y lo que no es nuestro cuerpo.
Y estas predicciones auto relacionadas dependen mucho de las señales sensoriales
del interior del cuerpo.
Y, finalmente,
las experiencias de ser un yo encarnado se relacionan más
con el control y la regulación que con averigur qué hay allí.
Así nuestras experiencias del mundo y de nosotros dentro de él
son tipos de alucinaciones controladas
moldeadas a lo largo de millones de años de evolución
para mantenernos vivos en mundos llenos de peligro y oportunidad.
Nos predecimos para existir.
Ahora, les dejo con tres consecuencias que se desprenden de todo esto.
Primero, así como podemos percibir erróneamente el mundo,
podemos percibirnos mal
cuando los mecanismos de predicción funcionan mal.
Entender esto abre nuevas oportunidades en psiquiatría y neurología,
porque finalmente podemos llegar a los mecanismos
en lugar de solo tratar los síntomas
en enfermedades como la depresión y la esquizofrenia.
Segundo:
Lo que significa ser yo, no se puede reducir ni subir
a un programa de software que se ejecuta en un robot,
por muy elegante o sofisticado que sea.
Somos animales biológicos de carne y hueso
cuyas experiencias conscientes se forman en todos los niveles
mediante mecanismos biológicos que nos mantienen vivos.
Simplemente hacer las computadoras más inteligentes no va a hacerlas sensibles.
Finalmente,
nuestro propio universo interior individual,
nuestra forma de ser conscientes,
es solo una posible forma de ser consciente.
e incluso la conciencia humana, en general
es solo una pequeña región en un vasto espacio de posibles conciencias.
Nuestro yo y nuestro mundo individual son únicos para cada uno de nosotros,